[Musique]
politique avec moi ce soir Émilie
Nicolas Michel CEG et Christian Dufour
bonsoir à vous trois
bonsoir alors vous avez entendu comme
nous cette entrevue avec la mairesse de
Longueuil madame Fournier qui trouve que
il y a un petit peu plus d'ouverture
aujourd'hui de la part de François
Legault le chef de la cape sur ces
demandes des villes ce qu'ils appellent
finalement une espèce de Plan vert en
fait c'est beaucoup d'argent qu'on
demande c'est 2 milliards par année
pendant 5 ans pour réussir à affronter
les changements climatique adaptés
surtout les infrastructures les villes
disent on n'a pas assez d'argent on a
vraiment besoin du soutien de Québec
madame Fournier nous rappelle qu'en
début de semaine monsieur Legault il
avait fermé la porte à cette demande
mais le soir même il a plus beaucoup
comme si tout à coup c'est un test de la
réalité qui s'est produit c'est
peut-être ce qui explique en partie
l'ouverture davantage aujourd'hui de
Monsieur le gaufre vous entendez quoi
Émilie
dans la rue dans la grande région
Montréal à Montréal même et aussi à
Longueuil le soi-même du refus ceci dit
c'est sûr que cette demande-là de plus
d'argent n'a pas des municipalités et
pas sortir comme ça en campagne
électorale comme une surprise c'est sûr
que ils ont eu des représentations avant
si les parties avaient voulu mettre ça
dans l'emplacement électorale dans leur
plan financier il y aurait pu le faire
donc là c'est sûr que je pense qu'on est
en train d'avoir un effort plutôt de
communication où on voit que ça que ça
que ça passe pas si bien que ça et que
étant donné que les maires des grandes
villes il y en a beaucoup qui confront
Unis qui ont des attentes crochus qui
sont capables au niveau de la
communication aussi de pousser un peu
plus je pense que ça a un effet donc on
réajuste le tir il y a rien de concret
sur la table et si il y avait voulu en
fait avoir quelque chose de concret sur
la table ça aurait pu être fait bien
avant le début de la campagne intervalle
mais il reste Michel que ça a de l'air
difficile pour les mères à chaque fois
de repartir au front avec des demandes
souligner le fait qu'ils ont de plus en
plus de responsabilités et effectivement
les changements climatiques affectent le
responsabilité mais ils ont pas plus de
revenus par exemple
et puis je couvrai la Ville de Montréal
dans le temps Dory était mère et puis ce
que j'ai entendu madame Fournier je le
lendemain à l'époque ça fait très
longtemps alors c'est en fait on peut
pas demander à des municipalités de la
taille de Longueuil de Montréal de
Québec etc Sherbrooke de travailler
strictement avec les revenus de la taxe
foncière ça c'est quelque chose qui va
pas du siècle dernier du siècle d'avant
et là on le voit là lundi il y a eu dans
un après-midi une chute de pluie qui a
été plus considérable que ce qu'on
reçoit normalement à Montréal dans un
mois alors et ça ça va se reproduire des
changements climatiques c'est ça que ça
veut dire très concrètement alors il va
falloir que le gouvernement du Québec
fasse quelque chose parce que d'une part
la ciel était municipale n'est plus au
point et tout le monde le sait depuis
très longtemps et d'autre part il va y
avoir des questions de changement
climatique qui vont affecter d'abord et
avant tout c'est pas répondre
bien souvent le gouvernement c'est
écouter de l'argent on en a prévu on a
des programmes mais madame Fournier ce
qu'elle répond elle c'est oui mais ils
sont pas flexibles et réussir à rentrer
dans la bonne case pour aller récupérer
cet argent-là c'est difficile en fait
ils demandent la flexibilité mais le mot
automnemi est revenu et ça on l'entend
de plus en plus de la part des mères
est-ce que c'est le temps de revoir
justement
la place des villes dans toute notre
structure politique
écoutez me dit Michel ceux qui suivent
l'actualité politique depuis un bon
moment comme moi c'est un vieux des
bosses qui revient cycliquement les
mères en fait qui demandent des choses à
Québec trouvent qu'on en a pas assez
rappelons que on fait souvent l'analogie
avec les relations de Québec avec Ottawa
mais c'est pas la même chose du tout
parce que on est en régime fédéral au
Canada les Québec qui s'ouvrait le
Québec qui souverain par rapport au
roman fédéral alors que les villes sont
des créatures des provinces il y a une
espèce de suggestion en fait
structurelle des villes à l'égard du
Valence du Québec un élément intéressant
qui s'ajoute dans ce qu'on vit
actuellement c'est que les villes sont
dirigées en bonne partie par des gens
plus jeunes et les gens plus à gauche
que monsieur Legault et les gens qui
sont au gouvernement donc vraiment une
espèce de connexion entre deux Québec le
contexte électoral est idéal c'est le
temps pour les villes de demander des
choses est-ce que les inondations ont eu
le temps d'impact que ça moi j'en suis
pas sûr donc monsieur le pas d'autres
choix que de s'adapter de s'ajuster
parce que si notre gagne
actuellement
ils sont plus à gauche ils sont plus
dans l'environnement ils sont plus
jeunes donc faut tenir compte ça fait
partie de la réalité c'est comme hier au
début une chose qui me frappé et puis je
pose du tout insulter c'est le groupe
parce que moi-même j'ai un âge canonique
mais on est monsieur Legault était plus
vieux en fait que d'autres donc ça
s'ajoute à ça c'est sain c'est normal
mais en même temps vous noterez que les
mers et les marais se gardent toujours
un ton très respectueux parce que le
rapport de force joue pas en faveur des
villes structurellement ils jouent en
faveur du Québec monsieur Lego qui veut
décider jusqu'où il va aller mais c'est
pas un nouveau débat c'est très très
vieux ça revient avec lui mais c'est pas
réglé c'est ça l'affaire alors c'est pas
c'est pas vrai sur
Christian en disant le ton des mères
effectivement est très posée madame
Fournier pas du tout un vote en guerre
quand elle parle des gouvernements ou
des chefs de parties en fait il y a
aussi la question on ne veut pas brûler
les ponts parce que après la campagne
suite on va avoir un bon rapport avec le
gouvernement qui sera en place
oui c'est sûr que c'est pas dans
l'intérêt demain ou d'une mairesse de
quelques municipalités que ce soit de
brûler des ponts avec le gouvernement
provincial gouvernement fédéral ceci dit
de leur dire que ce qui peut être
demandé sera jamais réglé je pense que
ça demande ça demande de la volonté
politique qui est déjà en fait des
choses je comprends que le débat est
vieux mais il y a déjà des choses qui
ont changé ça fait déjà quelques années
que Montréal a obtenu un statut de
métropole au niveau de la Fédération
canadienne des municipalités il y a
encore plus de grande ville qui est là
aussi depuis un bon moment il y a plus
de réseau qu'avant pour les maires
justement de pas être isolé les uns des
autres pendant que ils te font des
demandes des gouvernements provinciaux
du gouvernement fédéral et ça change
finalement le rapport de force le fait
que la population canadienne soit de
plus en plus urbanisée que la population
québécoise est de plus en plus urbanisée
fait qu'on a pas non plus dans la même
situation qu'on était au 19e siècle donc
c'est sûr que si la grande majorité des
gens vivent en ville les grandes villes
aussi ont un poids politique qu'ils
avaient pas avant et à un moment donné
c'est sûr que avec une constitution qui
a été conçue au 19e siècle quand c'était
pas du tout la réalité il va falloir que
il va falloir éventuellement vous le
permettrez jamais qu'on arrive en ville
en fait et qu'on arrive au 21e siècle et
je pense que justement ce changement de
garde là de génération pour l'instant et
surtout au minimiser une à la
municipalité s'il se fait aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale ils vont
éventuellement il va avoir des plateaux
de crochets là aussi on va pouvoir
avancer dans la même direction donc un
vieux débat mais dans un contexte où les
temps changent alors nécessairement ça
peut changer un peu les rapports de
force revenons maintenant sur le projet
du troisième lien ça a été réanimé la
controverse autour de ce projet-là avec
le débat le face-à-face d'hier et ça
forcer monsieur Legault a expliqué
davantage où on en est rendu dans les
études on va l'écouter
l'expliquer on parlait d'un pont à l'Est
on a pas étudié où on n'a pas étudié il
y a aucune étude qui
prend le projet là de tunnel 4 voies
dont deux voies pour le transport
en train de les faire les études ont pas
de zéro ça avance
expliquez-moi quelque chose comment on
peut affirmer haut et fort qu'on a
absolument besoin d'un troisième lien
alors qu'on convient ici monsieur
Legault convient qu'il y a ça repose
aucune espèce d'étude Christian
un peu parce que le premier ministre
c'est très cordial en fait la façon dont
il nous dit ça mais en même temps ça
fait très brouillon dans cette saga est
terminable du troisième mai moi je suis
capable mais il faut toujours en
reparler parce que toujours des éléments
à nouveau donc on apprend qu'il y a pas
de d'études en fait alors je représente
pas à jour les études moi la question
que je me pose sur le plan politique
plus général les gens beaucoup Monsieur
Lego quelque part et ce côté-là très
Jumet bon passe bien mais est-ce qu'à la
longue ce côté brouillon là ça fait très
brouillon ça peut pas lui dire
politiquement il y a une campagne
électorale seulement et est-ce que parce
que moi je vous avoue je ne pensais
après-midi je suis quoi il y a pas
d'études je parle un expert du tout
là-dedans mais je comprenais qu'il y
avait des études qu'elles étaient pas à
jour alors là le premier en plus
d'études donc je vais pas pouvoir mais
je connais pas ce point-là le dossier
mais sur le plan politique ça commence à
faire quand même beaucoup de
brouillonnerie
de chiffrer le projet a été capable de
présenter des dessins pour illustrer le
projet ça avait l'air sérieux ça avait
l'air d'être réfléchi ça faire le
et c'était fait sur une note à la fin
c'est ça le problème c'est que il y a
des études qui se font régulièrement
pour les sociétés de transport entre
autres origines destination ces
études-là montrent que c'est
probablement pas une bonne idée le
troisième mais donc il faut qu'il faut
quelque part qu'on nous trouve ou qu'on
nous montre qu'il y a une nécessité de
ça autre que les sentiments du parti au
pouvoir qui dit il y a trop d'attentes
près des ponts puis là chez moi qui est
GS
il faut quelque chose de plus sérieux
que ça et il faut pas oublier c'est pas
un projet gouvernemental ça fait mal
c'est une création des radios au Québec
c'est une demande des radios de Québec
le gouvernement dit oui à ça sans faire
d'études
[Musique]
je pense que c'est plus que brouillon
c'est c'est vraiment un problème de de
mettre la politique devant la science
devant la technique devant les choses
que le gouvernement doit vérifier avant
de dire oui ça fait quand même deux
campagnes que la carte traîne ce projet
Émilie en pensant évidemment que ça
allait jouer en sa faveur mais là on
entend les critiques on voit comment ça
rebondit dans l'actualité aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est possible maintenant que
le projet du troisième lien ça commence
à mettre la carte dans l'embarras à
votre avis vous vous connaissez bien les
régions de Québec aussi vous en êtes
issus
ben oui moi j'ai écrit récemment
d'ailleurs dans une chronique que je
veux dire
quand François
dans la soirée où il était venu en
entrevue que les gens de Montréal
causait trop de questions sur sur le
troisième pour moi le fait de pas avoir
démontré ses études ou de vouloir cacher
des études ou vouloir dire que
finalement il y en avait mais qu'on
voulait qu'on voulait se les mettre à
jour avant de révéler pour moi c'était
pour les gens de Québec et des vies qui
sont montré du mépris et je pense que ce
qu'on vient de voir aujourd'hui que en
fait on peut passer quatre ans cinq ans
si on compte l'année prélectorale de
2018 a poussé un projet de loi
c'est-à-dire un projet un projet comme
celui-là et que ce projet-là on réalise
qui est pas plus détaillé que ce qu'on a
vu dans le powerpoint essentiellement je
trouve que ça n'a aucun bon ça on parle
d'un projet de 7 milliards à peu près de
dollars le nombre d'argent le nombre de
dollars concrets justement vu que les
projets passer détaillés on peut pas le
savoir mais on est dans ces eaux là pour
quelque chose qui est aussi peu détaillé
que ça honnêtement j'essaie de comparer
à quel autre projet de cet envergure on
a déjà eu quand on a déjà parlé pendant
autant d'années sans avoir plus de
détails concrets sur sa réalisation je
ne sais pas à quel point à quoi comparer
en fait ce qui est en train de se passer
ouais
de sa mise en oeuvre
saga du Stade olympique je pense que
c'est déjà tout dire enfin ça lui
accroche des grosses casseroles ça c'est
bien certain bien entendu avec tous les
souvenirs qui vont avec les générations
un peu plus
âgées que vous ça rappelle aussi fort
bien Émilie mais Michel est-ce que c'est
possible effectivement que la CAC en
parle encore mais il croit moins
elle-même à ce projet là
il y a beaucoup de gens surtout à Québec
qui commence à dire regardez bien le
goût se cherche de façon de reculer
parce que c'est un fait que ça va coûter
extrêmement cher 7 milliards de dollars
ce n'est pas rien et ça c'est avant
qu'on a fait des études alors d'habitude
quand on fait des études on découvre des
frais cachés on ne sait même pas dans
quel genre de sol on creuse là alors
déjà au départ on n'est pas dans du
solide alors
là-dessus là il faut
littéralement faire ses devoirs le
gouvernement nous dit on les a prophètes
c'est déjà un aveu là il faut qu'il
fasse procureur en public les études
pour qu'il y a des voies publiques il y
a pas d'autres façons de procéder dans
un gars dans ces choses dans un projet
de cet envergure là
et saluant à tout le monde aujourd'hui
la candeur du Premier ministre quand
même parce que tu es pas obligé de le
dire moi j'en suis pas revenu qu'il l'a
dit et moi je me répète quelle tragédie
au Québec on s'occupe capable de lancer
des grands projets collectifs je trouve
que tout le dossier du troisième lien ça
devient tellement juste contentieux
c'est des sujets de division politique
idéologique normalement un grand projet
collectif c'est possible mais si
vraiment du sérieux derrière ça est-ce
que le gouvernement qui est au pouvoir
celui qui porte le projet doit pas
justement s'empresser de fournir les
chiffres de fournir finalement une
argumentaire qui repose sur des faits et
sur des sérieux on prend en parler toute
la fin de semaine on en parle on en
parle on a pas c'est clair
le prochain premier arrivé que Monsieur
Lego essaie de se désenliser mais c'est
pas évident bon on va parler du débat
parce que ça c'est que seulement hier
soir on a tous passé la soirée devant
nos téléviseurs avec ce face-à-face de
TVA j'aimerais savoir ce que vous en
avez pensé tout le monde a joué un petit
peu à ça aujourd'hui là qui est le
gagnant qui est le perdant grosso modo
Émilie votre bilan de ce débat hier
je pense que c'était très très difficile
pour beaucoup de personnes d'abord juste
de suivre ce qui se passait c'était un
format horrible à 5 personnes choisir
comme ça en terme de cacophonie c'était
très difficile de suivre l'ensemble des
débats je trouve que les journalistes
qui ont décodé là l'ensemble des faits
pour essayer de voir qui disait vrai qui
a dit qui disait faut là dans tous ceux
qui encore là je trouve qu'il y a ils
ont fait preuve de beaucoup de patience
et de rigueur parce que c'était vraiment
pas évident ceci dit je sais pas si les
électeurs sont beaucoup plus avancés
après après un type de déballage je
pense qu'il ressort c'est ce qui ressort
beaucoup c'est vraiment la question de
l'image est-ce que les gens ont de leur
poser est-ce que les gens ont la fatigué
parce que les gens c'est vraiment je
pense que là-dessus malheureusement ou
heureusement selon les perspectives que
ça situe parce qu'on n'a pas eu le temps
d'aller trop dans le profond dans des
propositions de de qui que ce soit il y
a eu c'est sûr qu'il y a quelques clips
qui sont sortis qui qui vont faire Jason
un peu plus longtemps mais dans
l'ensemble je pense qu'on était beaucoup
dans l'image étant donné le nombre de
sujets qu'on essayait d'aborder un petit
peu alors tour dimanche pas assez de
contenu passer de profondeur pour vous
Christian vais vous passer une belle
soirée l'avez-vous apprécié
vraiment je voulais décrocher je veux un
film sur Netflix que j'avais arrêté mais
je dis soyons sérieux je suis un
commentateur politique il faut que je
fasse les pas moi je recommanderais
vraiment à Radio-Canada pour le débat de
Radio-Canada de commencer par les sujets
qui allume le monde au début c'était
très ennuyeux à la fin c'est devenu
intéressant c'est un débat très
intéressant à la fin combien de
téléspectateurs sont restés jusqu'à la
fin je ne le sais pas donc commencez par
l'identité la langue des choses qui
allument pour que le monde reste un peu
pour le reste moi j'ai trouvé qu'avec un
certain contenu il y a pas eu de grands
gagnants de grands perdants mais c'est
pas assez des choses dans la mesure où
les gens sont restés là je trouve que
Paul Pierre
Paul Saint-Pierre
je trouve que bien performé il y a son
côté il est gentil mais en même temps
combattant c'est un vrai succès parce
qu'il y avait ça c'est normalisé comme
les écrits Paul journée dans la presse
ça c'était beaucoup parce qu'il y avait
une très mauvaise semaine à cause de ses
comptes de taxes pour payer tout ça
Gabriel Nadaud Dubois en fait tu as
beaucoup de prix de place maintenant
pour une fois j'ai trouvé qu'il était
très dialogue et regarde c'est mon
chemin monsieur Lego en fait était sur
la défensive mais c'est pas cassé la
gueule il y avait la plus âgée je
m'excuse de le dire par rapport aux
autres hier soir
c'est drôle je te demande de parler des
lunettes c'est ça qu'on respire ça ça
confirme ce que dit lui
et quand tu as Dominique Anglade moi je
trouve c'est elle qui a moins bien
performer même si sur le plan humain moi
je l'aime beaucoup je trouve qu'hier
était comment pétrir ce démêler mais
c'est quand même passé des des des des
des des choses Paul saint-père-plamondon
je trouve que scorer un peu raisonne
aussi et beaucoup de gens disent que
Gabriel Dubois se présentait comme le
vraiment le grand opposant au
gouvernement bon Michel avez-vous
l'impression qu'il change quelque chose
au narratif de la campagne se débat
et pas encore mais il met la table pour
une deuxième partie de campagne plus
intéressante moi je pense que
Saint-Pierre le Bondon inado Dubois ce
sont des marqués les deux plus jeunes
d'ailleurs c'est c'est intéressant
et moi je suis d'accord avec mon ami
Christian sur éric est obligé de faire
un couplet encore une fois sur les
mesures sanitaires moi je pense que ça
monte un sondage interne doivent leur
dire que la dernière semaine après avec
toutes les histoires de compte de taxe
impayés a été assez dévastatrice et là
on commence à resserrer le message vers
notre base vers ceux qui ont été les
premiers à rejoindre le parti
conservateur c'est pas nécessairement
une bonne nouvelle à ce moment-ci d'une
campagne et je suis d'accord avec
Christian sur Madame Anglade qui pas
juste au débat depuis le début de la
campagne malgré des propositions qui
peuvent être intéressantes réussissent
pas à sortir du lot remarquer que le
débat avait le problème et
c'est pas possible à gérer un débat
comme ça il fallait changer la formule
elle n'a pas été chargée j'ai hâte de
voir comment nos collègues de
Radio-Canada va s'en tirer avec ça parce
que vous savez on est seul politique qui
est fait pour avoir deux parties pendant
5 alors c'est effectivement
la campagne avec tous ces engagements
d'ailleurs il y en a un sur lequel je
vous ai mis aujourd'hui celui de Québec
solidaire avec ce projet québécraille et
Québec bus alors évidemment c'est tout
nouveau les gens connaissent pas
beaucoup mais essentiellement c'est des
lignes entre autres de train qui vont
relier les principales villes du Québec
alors par exemple Matane Québec Québec
Montréal Québec Sherbrooke Sherbrooke
Montréal il y a un besoin quand même il
faut le reconnaître au Québec c'est un
projet très cher par exemple Émilie un
commentaire là-dessus
mais en fait c'est que le besoin dans
les régions est tellement important il y
a le transport interrogbain en ce moment
aucun sens surtout dans
du Québec donc quand Québec solidaire
lance ça en fait il porte l'enjeu après
c'est aux autres parties de données si
eux sont pas d'accord avec ça qu'est-ce
qui feraient d'autres pour le transport
interrogbain dans les régions mais je
pense qu'il devrait au moins avoir un
consensus sur le fait que le statut est
absolument inacceptable pour les gens
qui voient du fleuve pour les gens dans
Gaspésie
rapidement là-dessus c'est un bon projet
c'est une bonne idée mais c'est quand
même un gros coup le 12 milliards
solidaire est toujours dans les
révolutions mais c'est vrai que c'est
une idée qui peut être intéressante une
cohérence par rapport aux positions de
Québec solidaire est-ce que c'est
réaliste ou pas je sais pas j'ai eu
communiquer il y a une demi-heure
j'ai trouvé ça drôle révolution
transparente mais ils sont toujours là
de choses là
même si vous êtes un peu
et donner des alternatives aux gens
c'est des alternatives seul à dire
on a peut-être été mieux de penser à
terme de bus que de train parce que les
voiles ferry ne leur appartiennent pas
parce que
un problème infini bon alors on dit
qu'il faut vraiment que j'aille à la
peau je vais donc vous dire merci tout
de suite merci bonne fin de semaine au
revoir